I love boba, and I actually went to the Flushing location and the Brooklyn location,...
...and I'm really happy to be in the Chinatown location to learn how to make this.
So, here, first part.
We're gonna do something, which is secret; I'll see you in a second.
The first step to making a perfect cup of Tiger Sugar...
...is to coat the cup in their signature brown sugar syrup,...
...but the exact method is a company secret.
It was not as easy as it looks, so...
All right, next part, we are going to put in the tapioca.
What is the difference between the boba and the pearl?
This is the most question people ask, the customers ask.
The boba, our size is a bigger one, and the pearl is the mini one.
So then, when they are added together,...
...it will be a very amazing, chewy texture when you're drinking.
Adding some ice.
We're gonna fill it up to the top, right?
Yes.
Next, we're gonna put our organic whole milk, then, we're gonna seal it.
It's automatic!
But look at that.
Wow, it's nice.
It's nice?
I think you're just being really nice to me.
These look like, more like tiger paws.
When done by one of the pros, this whole process takes only 10 seconds,...
...from ordering to receiving a cup of boba in your hands.